[Music]
hey you guys welcome to the tomes of
terror show
special edition 2021 tbr
show i don't know why i decided to do
this one
it's just like i just thought of it the
other day and i was like hey
since it's the end of the year and
hopefully
2021 is better than 2020 has been
and since this is kind of a new series
that i started i was like why don't i
just make a little special video
to post on the last day of 2020 or the
first day of 2021
and just kind of give people a heads up
on what my book pile is looking like
what i'm planning on reading in the next
year and what i'm gonna be making videos
uh you know reviewing so you guys can be
kind of up on
all the stuff that i'm gonna be reading
and maybe look forward to
one or another particular one now like i
said i'm gonna kind of show all these
books
now this is not to say that i might not
buy some other ones like in the interim
and put those up in the rotation um and
i'm not saying anything about like what
order that i'm reviewing them in or
anything like that
so these are just ones that i have in my
pile in no particular order
i'll be reading them and reviewing them
in the upcoming year so first i want to
talk about i got this one right here
this was a
recommendation from a listener this is
the black house by peter may and they
told me that this was like really really
really good book i guess this is set in
edinburgh scotland
and uh basically there's a murder that
takes place on this uh island
and it's supposed to be like similar to
this killing on the mainland and there's
this edinburgh detective so it sounds
sounds like kind of a
murder type story which i'm always
really into those
and i love that the main character's
name is finn mccloud which is possibly
the most
scottish name ever conceived but yeah so
this is uh
i'm really really looking forward to
this one because i've had a lot of uh
good recommendations about this one
so this will be one that i'm going to be
going to be reading and reviewing
uh pretty soon probably pretty early in
the new year here's another one that
i've seen come up on a lot of booktubers
channels um
some people really really liked it some
people were kind of mad about it but it
sounded like really intriguing
so this is nyctophobia by christopher
fowler
and the back of this one is basically
about an architect with a wealthy
husband
they move into this uh creepy old house
in southern spain
and it's on a cliff and everything and
uh
i guess like some creepy [ __ ] happens in
the house we always love a good haunted
house story
uh you know and this one is kind of like
house has a weird history
and there's something to do with her
being afraid of the dark
so this sounds like a really cool like
kind of gothic haunted house type story
and i really really like those
and i've heard a lot of good about this
one as well so i'm kind of looking
forward to this one too
here's another one i'm not really sure
if this one is
a horror novel per se or if it's a more
like a thriller um but this was one that
i saw recommended i think it was on
jordaline reads
and i really like a lot of her
recommendations actually if you haven't
uh subscribed to her
youtube channel she's super cute and
she puts up probably a couple videos a
week i think
and she's always got really really good
recommendations i've gotten a lot of
recommendations of books i've already
reviewed from her
show and uh there's another one too
called shades of orange
which is also very good but this one is
called the devil of
nanking by mo hader i think this came
out
back in i want to say 2004
i think this came out and like i said i
think it's kind of like it's about an
english woman in tokyo
and she's looking for a piece of lost
film footage
and we always love stuff about creepy
lost films
i'm really into that stuff like i said
there's that one that i uh
reviewed a while back experimental film
by gemma files
um so i that's a conceit that i like a
lot so i'm kind of looking forward to
this one and i've heard a lot of good
about this one as well
this is the back of it says it's kind of
comparing it to thomas harris
okay i'm liking that and ian rankin also
sounds pretty good
so yeah so this is kind of like more a
thriller so
i've heard this is also very good so
this is another one that's going to be
coming up soon if you remember a while
back i
reviewed a book called the nightmare
room by chris sorensen
and the cool thing about it it was as
small as my
little book review series is chris
sorensen himself
uh saw the review and was very happy
about it and actually offered to send me
the other two books in the series
uh for free so he sent them to me
and those are the hungry ones and the
messy man
so these are the other two in the
trilogy so
i'm assuming that this is kind of going
on because like i said if you remember i
go back and watch my review of the
nightmare room
it's about a guy who's like an audiobook
narrator and he
moves into this farmhouse that belonged
to his dad and um
all of this there's this really weird
like entity that lives down
in there and um i don't want to like i
said don't want to give too much away
and i've already reviewed it anyway
but so this is a continuation of that
and it was really really nice of
chris sorensen to send me these two
books so i will either be doing one
separately or i might do one just on
both of them together
i'll probably read them both at the same
time just so i kind of have because
otherwise i don't want to
and this will probably be soon because i
don't want to like forget what happened
in the first one because that kind of
happens like i'll read a bunch of books
and be like wait was this the book where
that happened or whatever
so yeah so i might read these two and
put them like in one show
so that'll probably be pretty soon here
was another one that a
listener had recommended and i don't
really know much about this one i think
it came out
in 2013 originally this is
hex by thomas old hoyvelt so i guess it
was originally in dutch
and it came out in 2013 in dutch but
then the english version didn't come out
until 2016.
so yeah so this is a dutch author um
written five novels won the hugo awards
so there you go
and uh this is ooh basically this is
about a town in the hudson valley
which is haunted by the black rock witch
a 17th century woman whose eyes and
mouth are sewn shut
so i'm into this already i love
old school witch stories and
i feel like there aren't enough of them
you know what i'm saying and i feel like
there aren't enough
old school witch movies either i know
they did gretel and hansel recently and
i guess they're kind of starting to make
a comeback but you know with
the witch the robert edgards robert
eggers movie and all that kind of stuff
but i really really like like old haggy
witches you know what i mean
i feel like in the 90s and early 2000s
they did too much like the sexy witches
and um that's cool but i don't know i
like creepy old witches
what can i tell you but yeah so so
creepy old witches from the 17th century
with their milestone shut i am all about
that and like i said this is a
recommendation from a listener so i'm
really really looking forward to this
one
i ordered it off amazon like the day
that they recommended it because i was
like ooh that sounds really good
so yeah that's definitely definitely
going to be high up on the priority list
this one
this one was another one that i kind of
heard a lot of people uh you know a lot
of other booktubers like talking about
and uh
it seemed like it's sort of got mixed
reviews but it sounded really cool like
i really like the sound of it
this is 12 nights at rotter house
by j.w ocker and it's basically i think
it's about a guy who's like a writer
and he goes to like he's like a
paranormal typewriter where he goes
around to all these like haunted
locations
and you know writes books about them and
i guess he goes to this
uh this abandoned haunted house and is
gonna stay in it for two weeks
and apparently it's real real scary so
um
that's what i heard anyway so i always
like like i said i always like
really scary haunted house stories
that's like really cool
so i'm very very excited about this one
i think this might be brain out
i tended this is terrible to say but if
i'm gonna order them off
amazon i usually get used copies because
i'm cheap well i'm broke um
so i try to get used ones but this one i
think was new because i don't think
there was any used ones available for
this
um so yeah i think i'm pretty sure this
is a new one but yeah so i'm looking
forward to this one
as well uh the haunted house is called
rotter house which is a [ __ ] great
name
so you know now this one right here i
think the first
yeah i guess it was like the first book
that i reviewed on this series
was if you see her by anya
alborn and uh like i said she's kind of
a writer that she's written like a [ __ ]
ton of stuff and her stuff like gets
reviewed all over
and i think i said on that review that i
had another book in my pile that i was
eventually going to get to um that she
had written as well and this one
has gotten like way better because if
you see her got like really good reviews
too but it seems like this one is kind
of like
when you're talking about anya alborn
this is kind of like the one that comes
up as people's favorite of hers
and this is called the devil crept in
and again you can see that's a used copy
sorry that's from the public
library because like i said i'm broke
this is basically about
uh a little kid i think it's told from
the point of view of a little kid who's
uh
whose little friend has gone missing in
the woods
and yeah this this is another one that i
first heard about on jordaline reads
like on her
channel and she just couldn't stop
gushing about this one
about how great it was and how it being
written from the point of view of like a
little boy named stevie um that it was
like really really well
written in that regard and how it was
like really really creepy and really
really [ __ ] up and i was like ooh that
sounds really good
so uh yeah so i definitely will be
reading this one soon as well
i just wanted to space out like some of
the authors because i had already done
one of hers
um i kind of want to get through some of
the other authors that i haven't done
any of theirs yet
you know before i get to this one so it
might be a little while but i definitely
will get to this one because i'm looking
forward to reading it here's another one
that i'm really excited about this is
actually a short story collection
uh this might be i don't think i've
reviewed any of these so far and this is
by the very well-known thomas legatti
this is called teatro grotesco
so there we go and uh yeah i've read
some thomas legatti before
um i think i've just read some of his
short stories like in various
anthologies and whatnot i can't remember
if i've read any of his like full-length
stuff but
i really really like like his writing is
like really original he has like a
really original distinct style
and i really really like short stories i
like writing them and i like reading
them
so i definitely had to pick this one up
um like i said short story compilation
so we'll see
you know we'll see where this one goes
kind of edgar allan poe-ish kind of hp
lovecraft kind of thing i'm kind of into
it so uh yeah this is
probably my first short story collection
i'm gonna do
now here's one that i think everybody
but me
that reads horror novels has read this
already
and has talked about how [ __ ] great
this book is and how
[ __ ] up and gross and gory and
everything and this is
the troop by nick cutter i mean this
has turned up this turned up on so many
people's like best of
lists i think it came out in 2014
originally
basically about a i think it's a boy
scout troop or something like that and
they're out in the
woods like on a um camping trip like in
canada somewhere like in the wilderness
and uh then this dude comes into their
campsite and he's like all like gross
and skinny and everything
and then uh [ __ ] goes very very sideways
from there um so yeah i've heard this is
like really [ __ ] up
and uh i'm here for it and as i said
this is another one that's turned up on
everybody's list and i feel like
everybody has read this but me so i
really really had to get hold of this
because i'm like this sounds like some
[ __ ] that's right up my alley
so yeah definitely looking forward to
this one as well now i got
two here by good old dan simmons
if you haven't read any dan simmons you
need to get on that [ __ ] because dan
simmons is amazing
i haven't read all of his books but i've
read several of them i mean seriously
you need to read the terror you need to
read like so many other ones
and this one of the books i've read of
his this is my favorite now
i've already read this one but i
but it was years ago i think this came
out in 2009.
uh this is drewed by dan simmons
and i read it very shortly after it
first came out and i
loved it and i just thought it was
amazing and
so i was like well when i thought about
doing this series this was actually the
first book that i
thought about doing so i definitely i'm
gonna reread it and
review it again for the show because
it's been like i said probably about 10
years since i've read it
if you don't know this is actually it's
like historical
horror fiction and it's about it's like
a fictionalized account
of charles dickens and wilkie collins
and they're trying to solve this mystery
of
this dude this creepy dude who you're
not entirely sure is human or not edwin
drewed
and that is actually like the last thing
that charles dickens
wrote in real life um that he didn't
finish was called the mystery of edwin
drude
so it's all so this book is almost kind
of like that
really happened but not you know what i
mean they're doing like a fictionalized
version of it
and it is so so good this book is so so
good
i loved it so much it's probably one of
my like favorite horror novels of all
time
and i'm really really excited i didn't
even have a copy because i think i
checked it out at the library like as
soon as it came out
and read it and so i was like when i
first conceived of doing the show and i
was ordering a bunch of books
this was the first one that i put in the
card i'm like i need a copy of this
because i definitely want to like review
this at some point and um
yeah so i really want to get to this one
now while we're speaking of
dan simmons i was at a used bookstore a
few weeks ago
and i saw this one right here on the
shelf and this right here i hadn't heard
of this one so i guess this one came out
i think this one came out in 2015.
so this is the fifth heart
and this is kind of a similar thing
where i feel like it's
like real life characters or real
characters like put into a such because
i remember like i opened it and i read
it's basically sherlock holmes and henry
james
come to america together in 1893
to solve the mystery of clover adams
who was the wife of historian henry
adams so it's basically
using real historical characters and i
know sherlock holmes wasn't really a
real person but you know what i mean
like using
mostly real characters and like one
fictional one and solving kind of a real
life mystery but with fictional elements
and as soon as i read that first like
thing because this is kind of like drew
but with different characters i was kind
of like oh i'm so on board i'm having
that
so yeah i bought this the other day so
i'm very very excited about this one too
i have not read this one yet i have read
drew before but i haven't read this one
so yay here's another one that i picked
up on this same
uh excursion to the used bookstore this
is monster
by frank peretti this is one that i i
remember when this came out i think this
came out
back in [ __ ] 2005. it was like a long
time ago
and i remember seeing this book
everywhere like i feel like everybody
reviewed it like i feel like i even read
some reviews of it or i saw it in the
library or something
but i don't think i ever got around to
reading it i very well may have read it
and just forgot i don't really know
because i did
read a lot of horror books back then and
like there was a time in my life when
i was going to the library every three
weeks and checking out like 20 books and
i would read you know so i
i was reading like a book a day pretty
much or a book every other day
and then every weekend i was going to a
bookstore and buying a book or two as
well
so i used to read like much much more
than i still do i don't really have time
to anymore sadly
but i feel like this is a book that i
probably would have read at the time
but if i did i don't remember if i read
it but yeah so i saw this on the shelf
and i was like ah why not it was you
know
it's in really really good condition
even though it was used and i think i
got it for six or seven dollars
but i was like so even if i did read it
before i don't remember anything about
it so it'll be totally fine but yeah
this is another one that
i'll be reviewing very soon now this
right here i don't know a great deal
about this book
it's called behind closed doors by b.a
paris
it's basically it's a psychological
thriller i think it came out in 2016
i want to say i just got intrigued by
this one i love psychological thrillers
i mean i have to say
i saw somebody might have been jordaline
might have been shades of orange i can't
remember but i remember somebody like
recommending this and talking about how
this was
i think it was like one of their
favorite books of last year um or
it was one of their favorite books that
they had read that year if not their
favorite uh book of the year
and it sounded kind of intriguing um so
i guess it's kind of like
it sounds like a really intriguing
premise because it kind of sounds like
from what i
could glean from the review and what i'm
like could figure out from the
text on the back is basically like
there's this couple who are kind of like
an upper middle class
couple and they seem like they're super
super perfect
but there's like all these weird little
things about them like
how does this wife like eat so much and
she's still skinny how come
she never answers the phone how come
like so there's like all these little
weird things that suggest that there
might be something weird going on
behind closed doors obviously so uh yeah
and i love that kind of [ __ ] oh
secret [ __ ] going on behind the facades
like seemingly perfect people i don't
know it just sounded really good so i'm
like what the [ __ ] so i just was so i
went to uh amazon and got myself a copy
so well we'll see what that's all about
very soon too here's another one that
a listener recommended and again this
sounds super cool
this is the hollow places by t
kingfisher which i believe is
a nom de plume i don't remember what the
author's real name is but i think that
that is a
that is a fake name that's a fake name
they also wrote
the twisted ones which is another one
that i want to get to because it keeps
coming up in my amazon
recommended because they're like hey all
these books you bought you might want
this one too and i'm like oh well
that also sounds good so i'll kind of
get to that one in a little while
but yeah so this one um also sounds
very cool it concerns like a weird it
seems like a weird museum like a house
museum like in rural north carolina
somewhere and i love that the
the tourist spot or the museum is called
the glory to god
museum of natural wonders curiosities
and taxidermy i mean
you know okay so yes so that i was like
okay i'm sold this is another one that
i'm really looking forward to and like i
said thank you to
whoever recommended this to me any book
recommendations you guys have i mean i
know i have so many to get
to and i don't know how soon it will be
before i can get to your recommendation
but and like i said i don't know what
order i'm going to end up reading these
in it'll just be in like whatever
order i feel like reading them in
basically like whatever mood i'm in
but um yeah this is definitely one that
i want to get to like sooner rather than
later because this sounds like kick ass
all right so i already reviewed one book
by grady hendrix
it was horror store the one that looked
like an ikea catalog which i thought was
delightful and charming and hilarious so
i've heard that this one
is even better uh this is also grady
hendrix
and it's called my best friend's
exorcism
and look at this cover
it looks like an old vhs tape with
stickers on it and everything
i said and i think i said this on my
horror story horror story review
i love when you go whole hog i love the
gestalt
of the look of the book being
thematically tied
to the story of the book that is just so
so satisfying to me i guess because i'm
a graphic designer
i just like the whole package to go
together so when you do [ __ ] like this
you just it just warms my cockles
seriously like even the back of it
look look it looks like an old like 80s
vhs i
[ __ ] love it but yeah so i've heard
this is set back in the 80s obviously if
you can tell from the cover
and it has to do with an exorcism
clearly but
it's also i heard it was also kind of
like um
you know a real like heartfelt like
friendship story
um and that was kind of like the the
heart of it and i thought that was like
a really cool idea
and i really loved horror story i
thought it was hilarious
um so i'm hoping this one will be good
and like i said i've heard this one's
even better so
we'll see how that goes i think this
came out in 2016.
so i think horror story might be a
little bit newer i can't remember what
year did that come out 2018 2019 i think
i said on my review i can't remember
but i think this one came out before
that but uh yeah so this is this is
definitely one that's going to be high
up on my list but like i said since i
already did a grady hendrix
not too long ago i will probably wait a
little while to do this one just so i
don't have the same author like too many
of them
close together i don't know why i care
but
this is another one that a lot of
booktubers have recommended
and it mostly sounds like a good it
sounds like kind of like a slasher which
sometimes i like some of those
like i said usually i like haunted house
stories or psychological
[ __ ] up psychological horror but i do
like a good slasher every now and then
this is kill creek
right here by scott thomas
so pretty much i think it's a pretty
simple story where it's basically like
you know slasher like there's a guy
going around like killing people picking
them off one by one
so uh yeah but i've heard this is really
good really well done
so uh we'll see how this one goes to um
seems like it's gotten a lot of positive
reviews so we'll see if we like it
now at this point i'm gonna get into i
know i already talked about drood which
like i said i
already read but from this point forward
i have a few more books that i want to
talk about um these are ones that i
have actually read at some point in the
past
but i liked them so much or they made so
much of an impression that when i
decided to do this series i decided that
i was going to
reread them to review for the show so
from this point forward these are all
books that i already had and that i had
already read
although in most cases it's been many
many years since i've read them
and the first of those is this iconic
[ __ ] right here
house of leaves mark danieleski i mean
i have to do this book i have to
i mean this novel is so
if you haven't read it like i know
there's some people that are just kind
of like what it's just too
thi this is not just a book this is a
commitment
i mean you have to if you're gonna read
house of leaves you really have to
commit this book is very long it is very
dense
it has a whole bunch of different story
lines going on and there's just
all this and it's just so complex but
it's
[ __ ] genius and it's seriously one of
the best horror books i've ever read
so i'm really really looking forward
sometime in 2021
i'm gonna re-read this [ __ ] right here
and i'm gonna review it for the show
have a big long discussion about it
because i know most of you have probably
read it because a lot of people have
said are you gonna do house of leaves
you're gonna do house of leaves yes i'm
gonna do house of leaves
like i said i have read it before but
it's been several years so
i'm really really psyched about getting
to read it again and getting back into
this [ __ ] because
this book is this [ __ ] me up and you
know what i mean because i love
i love books that are so immersive like
this that are almost kind of like not
i don't want to say like a puzzle but
sort of you know what i mean where it's
just kind of like
you get all involved like in all the
little mysteries and everything like
that i [ __ ] it's like an argy kind of
so um so yeah yeah i'm really really
stoked about rereading this i'll
probably get to this like fairly soon
this one might take me a while to read
so i might have to like read some other
ones
like while i'm reading this one too just
so i can keep up a week-long schedule
because i think the first time i read
this i can't remember how long it took
me to write
to read it i don't think it took me that
long but this is kind of a book that you
need to
take your time with and like sit and
stew in it you know what i mean you have
to spend time with it
you can't just just read it through and
be like oh okay yeah i'm done
so it's kind of one of those type of
things that's what i mean when i say
it's a commitment but yeah i'm
definitely going to be reviewing this
sometime this year so all right now just
got a few more paperbacks like i said
these are ones that i've read before
this is silk by caitlyn kiernan
i remember this being very good i
haven't read it in a while
i remember reading a red tree i think
which was also very good but yeah this
is basically
kind of gothy about a girl named spider
so uh yeah so i remember this being
really good so i'm going to be reviewing
this one as well
i think this was probably 15 years ago i
read this maybe something like that
but i just remember i don't remember a
lot about like what it was about i just
remember
sort of the feeling it gave me like you
know what i mean so
yeah so this is another one that i'm
going to be rereading and reviewing for
the show
now these ones i think i said on my
review of come out tonight by richard
layman that there was a time period when
i was basically going to the bookstore
and i was picking up a lot of these
paperbacks that were coming out i think
it was leisure books or whatever i can't
remember what the publishing company was
called
but they always put out they had this
kind of stable of authors which included
you know edward lee richard layman like
um jack ketchum stuff like that
so i was buying like a bunch of these
pretty much every week
and reading them and i have a bunch of
them so i might get to like some other
ones as well but these were just the two
that stuck out to me as being like the
most memorable
and uh so this was darkfall by steven
laws
now don't get confused because i think
dean koontz also wrote a book called
darkfall if i'm not mistaken this is not
that one this is basically about
um a bunch of people trapped in a
high-rise like at work and like
bad [ __ ] ensues so i'm gonna be reading
that one and
this one is called nightmare house by
douglas clegg
and i remember really really liking this
one a lot too
this is kind of like you know basically
a haunted house and it's
like an evil house kind of and uh you
know how much i love evil house stories
so yeah that's another one i'm gonna be
doing speaking of jack ketchum
you guys know that i have to do this
book
probably his best known one and the one
that they've made to
count them to movie adaptations of that
i know of they might have made more than
that
and the movie adaptations are good but
the book is way better
the girl next door i think this came out
of the late 90s 1998
it's actually loosely fictionally based
on
a true story about a girl who was kept
captive by a relative or a friend of the
family and like
basically tied up in the basement and
all the neighborhood boys like
would come over to this woman's house
and like go down to the bait hey let's
go down to the basement and like rape
this girl and torture this girl like i
said it really happened
uh sylvia lykins was the name of the
victim
um it happened in the 50s i think 1958 i
want to say or early 60s i can't
remember
but yeah so this is like a
fictionalization of that
this book uh i think i've read it twice
although it's been probably like five or
six years since i wrote it last time
this book you will need a bleach shower
afterward it is very very disturbing
the movies are also disturbing but
not nearly as disturbing as the book is
so if you've seen the movies and you
thought that was [ __ ] up
read the book and you'll be like okay
the movie was like not as [ __ ] up as i
thought
cause this book is [ __ ] up and then go
read about the real case because that's
really [ __ ] up but yeah i mean i love
jack ketchum i've got like a couple of
his other books too i might have off
season and some other stuff
so i'll probably do some more jack
ketchum as well but this was just kind
of the first one that came to hand
and i was kind of like oh man i got to
do this one this is a [ __ ] classic
so yeah i'll definitely be doing this
one soon next up got two more by
master of horror i suppose you could
call him peter straub
i reviewed mrs god not too long ago
which is basically like a novella
and that was actually in or a version of
it was in houses without doors which is
a short
story compilation which i have and i was
actually going to review that book
until i read mrs god and realized that
it was also in that book so i was like
well [ __ ] i don't know if i want to
review that whole book now i still might
but you know i don't know how it's going
to go
but i have a bunch of other peter straub
including ghost story
which i'm sure i'll probably get to even
though i feel like a lot of people have
probably read that because it's kind of
like a horror classic
these ones are just ones that i had
sitting around and these were the first
two that i grabbed
so i'm definitely going to do these two
at some point this is the hellfire club
which i remember being very good i like
that nice tacky
price thing up there which is actually
printed on there it's not even a sticker
so you know
and that and i got lost boy lost girl
so i have read both of these but it's
been a while
so i'll review those at some point
probably be a little while because like
i said i just did mrs god not too long
ago
so i want to give i'll give peter straub
a break so we can get some other like
authors in there
now this book here i feel like this came
out back in 1999
now this was given to me as a gift by a
friend of mine
back then like probably a year or two
after it came out this is called
the rainy season by james p blaylock
i don't hear a lot of people talk about
this one but i
really really dug it there was something
like really i really really liked the
atmosphere of it
it's kind of like set in southern
california it's very like
it was seemed like very gray and rainy
and stuff it kind of reminded me of that
stephen king book bag of bones if you
remember that one
it kind of gave me that sort of vibe
it's just it's really cool it's like
kind of
mysterious you know there's a mystery
and all this other stuff
and um you know there's an old well and
it's like i love [ __ ] like that it just
reminds me
of [ __ ] that i used to read when i was
younger and so i really liked him and i
feel like a lot of people don't talk
about this one but i've had it for
[ __ ] ever
and i it was one that made a big
impression
like back when i read it and i probably
wouldn't have sought it out on my own
uh if somebody hadn't given it to me so
i think
my friend liz gave it to me now that i'm
thinking about it for my birthday or
something like that
because she had read it and she thought
it was really good so yeah so i've read
this before and i'm definitely going to
reread it for the show because
i feel like it's really good and it
seems like it's a little bit
underappreciated
i wanted to mention too before i close
the video out
is that i also there's two more books
that are on my list that i actually
can't show right now because one of them
because it's an ebook
and i don't have the cover and the other
one because
i ordered it but it hasn't arrived yet
so the first one of those books
was actually the e-book version was sent
to me by the author evan whitmer
and it is a short story like a
surrealist short story compilation
called pages from the pizza crows
so um he was nice enough to like he uh
sent me an email and was like hey you
know do you want an ebook version or a
print version
and you can review it on the show and i
said yes indeed surrealist horror i'm
all about that
so um so yeah so he sent me an e-book so
i'm going to be reading that and
reviewing that as well and the other
book that i have ordered from amazon but
haven't received yet
is no one gets out alive by adam neville
which came out in 2014
this is a book that kept coming up on so
many people's lists like this is the
scariest [ __ ] that i've ever read
and it came up on more than one person's
list like saying that and i was like
okay well that sounds like a
recommendation
so i went online and ordered it for some
reason i couldn't find like um
i used one or even the used ones were
kind of expensive
but there was just so much hype about
this book but i'm like i gotta [ __ ]
read this
so i ordered it i think the copy order
was like 30 bucks or something like that
which is like normally more than i would
pay
for uh picking up pretty sure it's a
paperback but it was just seemed like it
was hard to get hold of
so i was kind of like ah [ __ ] it you
know what i mean it's i'm sure it's
really good because i've heard nothing
but good things about it but yeah so the
adam neville
no one gets that alive i just don't have
it yet so i can't show it to you
and the last one i'm going to talk about
so this video isn't 40 bajillion hours
long
is another classic this is by good old
richard matheson
man i love richard matheson oh i didn't
bring it over here but i think i have
dual which is a big huge
compilation of a bunch of richard
matheson's short stories and screenplays
and stuff like that i might get around
to reviewing that
one day too like i said i feel like it's
it's kind of almost easier to do a novel
than it is to do short story compilation
but i don't know i don't know why that
is and i'm definitely going to do that
thomas legatte short story thing so i
don't know what the hell i'm bitching
about but whatever
so yeah so uh this right here stir of
echoes
this came out in 1958
novella it's pretty short and if you
guys watch our
movie retrospectives we have done a
movie retrospective on
the movie version of this with kevin
bacon
which if you haven't seen it which came
out in 1999 i think yeah it came out the
same year as
[ __ ] the sixth sense which is one of
the reasons why it doesn't get
remembered as well because the sixth
sense kind of like
stomped all over everything they're like
oh we're the big ghost movie for the
year
so this came out like almost the same
time as that movie and kind of got
buried even though i honestly think stir
of echoes
is probably a better movie and i really
really love the book the
the movie is similar like it did change
some things
but you know it's similarly themed like
similar kind of [ __ ] happens
but i love love love this book i love
richard matheson
and this is just such a good novella and
uh so definitely definitely want to do
this one i might do
um i might do i am legend too uh at some
stage but like i said that seemed kind
of like we're running into with peter
straub and ghost story it just seems
like
it's so iconic that i feel like so many
people have read it
but maybe not you know maybe i'm
over maybe maybe i'm over judging like
how many people have read it
maybe like younger people are watching
this and they don't you know haven't
read stuff that's
oh that's that old or that's classic or
whatever so maybe i should just like say
[ __ ] it and not worry about
because i feel like it at first i was
kind of trying to get like more newer
horror because i hadn't read a lot of
that
but then i was kind of getting requests
for stuff that was a few years back and
then
when i was watching other people's
channels it seems like it almost doesn't
matter like what year the [ __ ] came out
because some of the stuff i realized
you know i just bought it off amazon
thinking oh maybe it's new or it came
out in the future the last few years
and some of them were like really old
someone were like 10 years old 20 years
old and i didn't even realize
you know what's i think i said when i
was talking about that michael mcdowell
book the elementals
it's like i didn't even realize this
book came out like [ __ ] 1982 or some
[ __ ] like that
it's like as i saw like a review of it
and i'm like oh that sounds really good
and i just bought it and i was like oh
this is really old
but yeah so i feel like it doesn't
really matter it's just kind of like
movies
and honestly books age even less
probably
because you're not seeing like janky
special effects or anything
so uh so yeah this one here from 1958
definitely want to do
this one and like i said if you haven't
seen the movie you should definitely
check that out because the movie is
[ __ ] good
all right so that'll do it for my little
special edition tomes of terror hope you
guys enjoyed it hope you guys are
excited about seeing me review some of
these books like i said it's not going
to be in any particular order i don't
really know
what order i'm going to end up reviewing
them in i just have like a big pile in
my office and i just kind of grab one
and that's not to say that if i don't
like if somebody sends me a book or
if i see another book available like at
a bookstore or you know on
online or whatever and that sounds like
really awesome and i might order it and
i might end up
reviewing that one before any of these
but i just wanted to give you guys an
idea of what was in my pile and what was
going to be coming up
in 2021 as far as book reviews go
so uh happy reading you guys and i'll
see you on the next one
bye